[Music]
once upon a time
france and belgium made up one of the
best counter-strike regions in the world
they had talented players kenny stuck in
the site finding more that's brilliant
in kenya's again up close oh my goodness
kenny s
the no scope on the third this guy's
absolutely insane
stacked rosters welcome to the stage
ariel what a final that was amazing
that was incredible these guys and of
course
a lot of trophies
but eventually something went wrong and
french cs
fell off a cliff that was an absolute
slaughter i don't think anybody went
into this thinking that
renegades as individuals and as a team
they were going to outplay them
in terms of individual skill in terms of
tactics they were all over titan from
start to finish
so what the hell happened i mean there
was personality problems that you know
prevented
proper structure within those teams
the french belgian counter-strike scene
is like a good soup
both require specific ingredients to sit
together in the pot for a long time
but both also require a steady hand
somebody who can
balance it all into cohesion while still
letting the individual flavors stand out
and both if left unattended and uncared
for will become stagnant and flavorless
france and belgium did have a presence
in 1.6 teams like
ldlc emulate and 3d max put french cs on
the map
but very game's performance in source is
what really turned the scene into
a powerhouse
very game's various incarnations
included plenty of future french cs
royalty
from existence to nbk to shocks to kenny
s to happy
and they were dominant the m4
apex pushing his way onto the cat trying
to make sure they don't take it exists
and takes on one
apex gets two more one on the scream and
hork's dragons are gonna be pushing down
short b and that's flashes and spray
going everywhere with smith one two
three with that to go fourth one
can he get the last one fifth one oh my
god smith gets amazing deagleys
as french cs emerged as a hotbed of
world-class talent
that talent started to develop egos egos
that would eventually plunge the scene
into chaos but as the french cs scene
was transitioning from source to go in
2012
all those players were still getting
along very games were cementing their
status as one of the best teams in the
world
bolstered on by rivalries with nip and
clan mystic a french team where
kiyoshima made his name
no situation
by the beginning of 2014 very games ran
out of money but existence nbk
smith's shocks and scream stayed
together and played as titan
at the same time kenny s found himself
unclan mystic
honing his now legendary off skills
and happy was holding on the fort as a
formidable igl for ldlc
he's not going to check the corner he
comes to gets the one kill needs a
little bit more
one click on flush will be enough he's
gonna get the head shot fantastic for
the smoke happy
oh you gotta be kidding me pistols out
all of mice has got to go down
happy gets the quad kill but things were
about to get a
whole lot less stable between september
2014 and february 2017
the french cs scene exploded and
reformed in three
massive roster shuffles a metric ton of
relationship drama
and a general unwillingness to play with
people from outside the scene
but over the years the tangled petty and
confusing mess that is french cs
produced a few historic and downright
beautiful moments of counter strike
they turn away here harvest tsm he's
looking for the shot but he's not going
to get it and it's all going to come
down to the natural board killer
who dunks the date straight on to
kerrigan but it's a 1v2 now a 1v1
and nbk needs to pace himself no he says
no i'm going to take this round
so september 2014 the first french
shuffle
kenny s was pulling off clutch
performance after clutch performance on
a newly revamped titan roster
kenny has the bomb and that's a one
crucial fact here
looking for it gonna get the one kill
and there comes actually
what are you kidding me he picks up the
kill and look at that
the excitement titan take out nip
over at ldlc happy was dealing with a
hole that apex cali and maniac left when
they went over to titan and he nearly
retired when ldlc officially disbanded
in early september
shortly after the igl legend found
himself back under the ldlc banner on a
mini french super team
and roughly two months later happy
steered france towards its first major
win in counter-strike history
pacing himself he's gonna spot nbk first
he goes down
and ldlc they pick it up oh look at that
they can hardly believe it
they're hugging each other and it must
be an unreal sensation
but kenny s and titan didn't even make
it to the major
a week before dreamhack winter valve
banned cali for using cheating software
the week before he joined titan
and the team immediately dropped him but
in a controversial move
valve decided to ban the entire titan
roster from playing in the major
the moment that kenneth had been waiting
for the chance to prove that he was one
of the greatest counter-strike players
ever was gone
post-major titan continued to post poor
results despite their strong roster and
ldlc actually ended the year on a high
note alright well congratulations to
ldlc they have won
in a 3-0 sweep the g2a.com european cup
and they have taken home five thousand
dollars in 2015 team envious entered
french cs
signing happy shocks nbk smiths and
kiyoshima as their inaugural
counter-strike roster
but there was a problem shocks and nbk
despite both being legendary players in
their own right
didn't like each other in fact there
were plenty of times where any number of
people in the french scene just
didn't get along so that initial envious
roster that looked
so good on paper it didn't last and they
shuffled like
every french team does they did have at
least
one moment worth remembering though and
well that's what happens when you go
around the corner happy with wandig
oh and another one oh the third
happy we could get another one here too
dupree
debris is like sweating bullets half
he's gonna get the quad killing the ace
what is this
after the dust finally settled on that
shuffle kenny s got his chance to shine
at a major
they need a bit they need to go big and
kenny's gonna go ahead and peek in a
second man and he gets the flick on his
lightning fast and what made his
performance even more incredible
is that he carried games despite the
recent off nerfs
kenny's signature close quarters
aggressive style
gone but he battled back and though he
couldn't style with the offer he once
did
he and his team put up another major win
for the french csc
this time around envy they clinch it 2-0
no mistakes made they get the job done
and once again a french team stands at
the top of the world
after the major though envious fell into
a slump and titan went back to posting
poor results
in early 2016 titan dissolved partially
due to financial issues stemming from
cali's back ban
but the roster was quickly picked up by
g2 esports
and here's where things get silly again
leading up to
during and after the mlg major in 2016
the french cs scene went through another
round of petty drama
and to the surprise of almost no one
except maybe the french players
themselves
the level of play that was once
considered dominant just
continued to decline
but there was one last great hope for
the french sea
after poor results of the 2017 e-league
major in atlanta
g2 brought out nbk kenny s and apex
creating the first true french super
team by teaming them with shanks and
body
even smith was there as a coach
obviously we know shock is a fantastic
clutch player he's going to win tons of
clutches you've already got something
like mbk
as well so i think this team has all the
pieces to be a potential world number
one now whether they'll do that
i think that's probably the hardest
prediction you could make in the history
of csgo because we've never had a period
like right now
with the new fanatic with vertis bro
still here with astralis looking amazing
with sk gaming adding phelps therefore
you can't really say
predict either way that g2 is or isn't
going to become the more than one but
they certainly have the parts and the
style for it potentially in terms of how
they fit together in the balance
what made this rocker significant wasn't
just that it seemed like sharks and nbk
had set aside their differences
it was that for the first time in the
history of french cs
kenny s and shocks were playing together
on the same team
it was unprecedented as we are going to
see mbk here
trying to hold from inside he's spotting
nades coming from heaven he knows that's
where they're coming from they're trying
to spill it
but they can't make it through g2 they
take it this is still their home soil
look how excited
apex is they should be g2 got off to a
slow start before picking up big wins at
dreamhack tours 2017
and they're just one kill away and it's
gonna happen 16
to nine sg2 are your dream hack masters
champions
amazing and the esl pro league season
five finals
one to go and there it is
g2 but while the results were
consistently good
they weren't great and for a team with
all of french cs's hopes on their
shoulders
anything short of greatness was enough
to bring back old animosities and
that knee-jerk instinct to shuffle at
the boston major g2 made top 8 for the
first time
ever and then they became a stepping
stone for cloud9
and once again the french super team
shuffled
so for this reason we've decided what we
decided which is
giving a team with mbk as a captain
a chance to prove themselves for a
certain period of time
and then define what we do next to some
extent it does make sense
if a new team isn't working out you
change it but the problem is that the
french scene never gave any of these
so-called super teams a fair shot
all of these people couldn't set aside
their egos for a minute and just settle
their differences
the fact of the matter is sometimes
victory requires compromise
and if you can't even do that then
eventually there won't be anything left
to shuffle
the very best of french cs aren't ready
to retire and honestly
they don't need to they just need to
find a way to work with each other
and the up-and-coming crop of new french
talent the most recent french shuffle
from october 2018
gave them that chance in vitality would
love to get a little bit more here
inside
he's got himself a triple kill with a
scout quad from taiwu
and it's into a war 3v1 and cyborg gets
he is
the players are coming by he is the
first king connected to the second and
the august exactly what you need as
they're all lining up for ammoniac
the french counter-strike scene isn't
dead contrary to what reddit would have
you believe
they've got a real shot at becoming the
best in the world once
again if they can find a way to solve
all the infighting and incorporate their
veteran talent
and the new blood french counter strike
could find its way back to the top
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages